here's what would happen if World War 3
started tomorrow
millions of people would likely die and
the Earth would take decades if not
centuries to recover especially with
some of the tools and weapons that
countries are using these days
soldiers on the ground might have
exoskeletons making it easier for them
to carry heavy equipment over long
distances but the war might not be
fought on land or in the sea or Sky it
might be fought in space
but the most terrifying thing about this
war would be nuclear weapons a nation
could have all the resources and people
they need but if a nuke gets dropped on
you it's game over and if one country
drops a nuke it's to stop another
country from doing the same and then
another soon the entire world would be
destroyed
who would win this war but absolutely no
one a full-on World War 3 would have a
massive impact on the world as a whole
so